on this episode we talk about app
launches we talk about health and
wellness professionals and we talk about
fruit and vegetable stands
Gary B yep right and that goes yeah yeah
I saw that update but I haven't played
with it that's cool so like when I we
have so big give her like a mustache
like a bow right now classic Gary 206
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 6 of
the askgaryvee show India
d-roc on the scope Garrett green in the
house Tyler I mean this is a full house
just missing Uncle Jesse feeling pretty
good feel ready I saw what you know it's
funny I've got a I've got an interesting
travel schedule tomorrow the 3:00 a.m.
wake-up call the four am play right but
I was really excited so some of the
comments come through on episode 205
people felt that I was in good form
because I've been out of the saddle and
I feel I actually feel even stronger for
episode 2 of 6 so India with that like
you know I feel like we should have
classic route here just classic like
we'll do our little show thing oh I
still have a watch that I want to watch
that right after this we're gonna do it
we're gonna roll it we're gonna do a
little show thing and we're just gonna
we're just gonna ask questions I'm gonna
give answers that are gonna make an
impact oh great so you ready ready let's
get into the show
by the way real quick before we get into
this show ah this is a I'm trying to
figure out how to say this I've been
thinking about how to address this you
guys are so sweet
let me make a very strong statement I'm
always so humbled and flattered and my
ego is scratched in such a good way I'm
always willing to take a selfie so many
of you were like
obviously with the virality on facebook
and stuff of that nature I can feel the
heat you see what's going on we're doing
dailyvee so many of you were looking at
me and then tweeting like I wish I
stopped and said hi
like I'm like you can never bother me
I'm so flattered I'm always ready to do
it it's it's an incredible
accomplishment I feel incredible about
it and just I feel a lot of people
lately have been like I and me up then
tweeting it and I see them and I knew
that they like recognized me and I wish
they stopped I would have loved to give
some naps say thank you take a picture
so how about the other day when I when
the guy's phone died you know by this
you know about this do you I've told you
about this uh some guys phone died what
do you like came up I took it online and
emailed it home very sweet my sweet guy
India Mikkel asks do you ever pick and
choose which clients you work with based
on how they do their business yes I know
so the answer is yes but many times I
don't so you know I'm running a business
I'm not and now I would you know for
example we have had big clients
potentially come through here which I
thought were in an industry that would
cause too much in a and very honestly in
a politically correct world in a world
that we have a lot of you know I don't
want to call liberal thinkers but like
there's absolutely things that you have
to do as a CEO that you make decisions
on who you do business with based on
what you think is in the best interest
of your business for me goes in reverse
and three orders what's the best
interest for everybody like like my
responsibilities to everybody here which
then is in essence the logo and then my
feelings are third and so I've actually
not taken on business that I thought
would not be in the best interest of the
feelings and emotions and thoughts and
strategies of my employees though they
might not have 100,000% aligned with me
let's say I was 80% there but I felt the
collective was 100% there and I take
that responsibility and so you know I
never judge based on how they run their
social media or marketing because that's
what were there to fix if that's where
mikhail michael was going
and I don't blame company like you know
you could have one rogue CEO that makes
this wine company a bad company but then
if she or he is fired then they are a
good company so I also try to quantify
that but yeah it's run through my mind
I've absolutely made decisions look the
people you surround yourself with is an
indicator to who you are man it's just
the truth and so my clients are
representation of Who I am but I have no
problem having alcoholic brands sugar
water like these are not things that
scare me I'm not hypersensitive but if
you make you know bombs or and that's
not a real life example or if you're two
Patriots like for example I would never
take the Patriots as a client no shot
yeah buddy asks what's your advice for
health care Doc's who want to add value
using social media to promote wellness
and attract ideal patients this is good
I'm glad you asked this question
actually think that's something we need
to challenge ourself on a show oh here's
something that the audience can do I
don't think I've heard but I have a new
search engine both the questions and
answers Stefon pop it up good commercial
time put it right here I want it okay
it's unbelievable like you have a lot of
questions for me
they've all been answered or at least
the ones on the show and now they're
very searchable if you were part of the
vaynernation the maniacs out there if
you search something that you got zero
results for please tweet me and I'll
start passing it on to you like I feel
like I'm really happy you asked this
question because it's getting this
Johnson genres and I think I want to go
more profession based than the 200s I
want to do more I'm a contractor but so
please actually can we all stand up and
rise I haven't been doing this
consistently and I haven't been asking
you if you please ask a more specific
question to your industry right now use
the hashtag askgaryvee or that up here
as well everything for you plus I love
double checking I love when you forget I
get mad and and so uh that's a great
question so that question is based I'm a
health I want to make sure I got that
one little piece because I yeah you know
I think you go longtail what's the name
buddy you know buddy I think it's a
really important thing too
should go longtail and I think one of
the biggest things that I mean by that
lawyers real estate agents insurance
brokers wine guys perfect timing
the reason this popped this old show
that I used to do
he wasn't it popped was because I was
really giving my best advice and I
didn't care if he came to Wine Library
and bought this or he bought it
somewhere else I was trying to provide
you value as long as you care more about
the first part of your question the
second part of your question you will
win as long as you want to provide more
value then you want customers you will
win as long as that's 51 and the second
part of your question is 49 you will win
so what does that mean that means you
put out on video things that might
actually solve people's complete
problems with them not ever coming into
your ecosystem and becoming a client so
many people in marketing so many people
in information and services want to give
you a little taste so that you then come
into their full circle I have been very
successful in going the other route
which is giving so much and then using
that equity that guilt that
word-of-mouth to be the gateway to
business so I would tell you buddy that
you need to put out the best advice and
content that you can that your videos
and pictures and audio and written words
need to be here's a scenario here's
exactly what you should do and that
might be remedied on over the counter
that might be remedied with some old
Western point of view that might be
remedied by somebody going to a clinic
or a place that has nothing to do with
you and you have to be okay with that if
you are not okay with that all of your
actions aka all of your content will
feel that way to all the end consumers
and then they will feel that it is
transactional or that it is actually a
gateway so many of you watch the show
because I think you deeply inherently
whether you understand it or not realize
I'm trying to put out the best content I
can here and there is no comma something
there is no this ends or in the middle
of it I'm trying to sign you up for my
school or this and that yes every three
years and we just went through it you or
two years you'll hear from me on like
buy my book buy my book but no way my
name Jesus I don't know if you guys have
noticed I've been I've even been less on
book selling the last 45 days than I
expected I've been zero I think I did
some of the other day like I mean
one like so I think your actions speak
louder in your words so one more time I
want to hear that way the question is
framed stop for a second do that
I don't think you've you had advice
here's the advice make pictures videos
and written words and audio pieces of
content that bring people value if
you're a good health professional you'll
know what to do because I really
understand why and I knew what to do the
comma part needs to be the trust that
that content is actually gonna bring you
what you actually want to happen which
was the second part of the question
you're not watching the askgaryvee show
because you don't care about the
business ramifications this is a
business show right it just happens to
be a business show that is doing
business in a higher manner than the
rest of the market how they how they
feeling about of the scope do they know
that you're holding it do they know the
famous d-roc is you're unbelievable you
should be making movie skills that are
holding this he's fancy in - you - you -
no no you - you two are super fancy yes
that's true d-roc is very fancy but
India you gets you get stopped
everywhere you take selfies you're but
your your your your you know we haven't
been doing askgaryvee and dailyvees
antara Saudi rocks clearly close the gap
on the Fame race but you know what
Stefan have a have Zak make a little
chart for me I want a real good design
here right now put it right here
I want a Fame graph with India's face of
the Iraq and like I think we should
bring it up once every eight or nine
shows and see who's winning in the fame
you know oh but that might be because
he's hustling harder but I don't think
that my what about when I saw you in the
wild on snapchat yeah Patrick asks what
did you learn selling baseball cards
that I could apply to selling vegetables
at my first farmers market coming up
Patrick this is amazing watch their eyes
that's what I learned in baseball cards
as you guys now know or if you don't
know if you go to my website right now
link it right here you got a lot of work
to do this come out next week I date
trade attention and build businesses
when you day trade attention eyes and
ears are very important what I learned
and this is by the way this is a stereo
I would literally be on a baseball card
show and I'm gonna I'm gonna paint it
for you because it's really important I
would literally like I would get there
at 6:00 7:00 a.m. the show would open at
9 7 8 a.m. and I would have my table and
I would sit there for hours
Garet pay attention and I would sit
there for hours and I would do this and
then this and then this and I would look
and I come around and I'll never forget
this I would always come around I try to
understand it from that perspective I
would pay attention to what the other
dealers were doing and so I'd be like
okay he has a lot of boxes here so like
if I go white space here I gave a lot
I'm a kid I'm 13 I'm 14 and I'm thinking
about how when you walk through this
small and if you just saw that guy's
table what does my table have to do so
that you're not you know there's 80
tables here what would you have to see
there that would then make this stand
out in the context of that and that and
then what could I do and if you look at
this table this is the big punch line
right the orange thing so let's call
that the ken griffey jr. rookie card do
I put in the middle but then it's hidden
by all the other cards do I put a top
left corner and it's funny even as a kid
and this is how I understand websites
I understood that's how people read so I
would put my flashiest hardest core
hottest items in the top left corner
because I understood that's how the I
would look at it be like whoa there's
stuff here you know to me that's a
really interesting insight to how I roll
it's how I think about the first five
seconds of this video when you watch it
it's how I think about my tweets it's
the it's how I think about my opening
line when I give a keynote speech that
all of you have seen in the cliche how
many people know who I am who don't know
who I am everybody raise your hands if
that hurts
hahaha humility because I'm about to
deploy a lot of ego so you know for all
my yeah I'm quite calculated and that's
how I thought about it and so what I
would tell you Patrick is it Patrick pay
attention to the eyes understand the
context think about the parking lot flow
of the vegetable market and think about
what most people walk through and how do
you have and do you have a vegetable
that nobody else has
do you have a better price on something
that nobody else has understand what
they just saw understand where they're
going where's the bathrooms in the
porta-potties where's the honey lady
like there's the sausage guy like I'm
the only person that sells pickles in
this entire a row think think think and
then when you sit down and watch in your
first table just watch that's all I did
I was like a weird I look like a weird
dude probably because I would just watch
and I would watch like a goddamn hawk
and I would just watch and see their
eyes and then adjust and be like maybe
that wasn't working counter punching
their attention that was cool right
you like that the whole like that was
neat right you like that because that
was like I tend to be very clouds but
that was very dirt I don't go dirt a lot
like it's my try to go dirt for you guys
but clouds is how I win but like I got a
lot more dirt in me than you think
that's why I think the industry specific
questions are good too
good observation India that was the
graph a fan that was a graph of fame
good job is Fei Long right sure apple
pie parties asks how do you know if you
should continue to bootstrap or bite the
bullet and accept investor funding a P P
this is a tough question for everybody
every situation is different this is why
it's I struggle with dirt because the
truth is I can't give you an answer
without really knowing your business
from knowing you every one of you that's
sitting there deciding between and do I
take on investment or do I continue to
bootstrap has so many other variables
where are you in your personal
relationship how sick and tired of you
are you of bootstrapping you know how
big of a business do you have way too
many of you are taking on investment
when your business can only be worth
three to five million dollars and then
you're giving up such a big percentage
and your patients over three to five
years would have made you a lot more
money then you're getting a percentage
of the only three to five million
top-line revenue business that you have
so you know the truth is India that
every business has its own variables
what I will tell you is that I think
money will get tight soon I think we've
been living it through fairly good times
even though most people don't realize
that especially
our deaf culture though the mass
economics in America are okay the
startup culture the people that are
building businesses in the ship in an
environment that would watch a show like
this have had it pretty good and and I
think that I think that will dry up
shortly and so I think that um I think
that if you need the money
you should go and get it immediately if
you don't need the money and it's more
about do I accelerate or do I keep
grinding I think that comes down to the
individual and their situations at home
life their level of patience how much
they enjoy the process I kind of alluded
to like almost sabotaging myself on
dailyvee the other day because I love
the process so much so I hold off on
gratification Devin asks how crucial do
you think in apps launches product hunt
that's a really good question again a
layered question I altima to make a
great product the answer is not that
much my snapchats launch was
non-existent
no freaking snapchat launch party there
was no like big to-do you know like like
you know Instagram cuz system was in the
ecosystem he did get the Kevin roses and
the Pharisees and things of that nature
but you know and that was just in a
small pie because the tech space is so
small I would argue stunningly little I
think we've seen a ton of people have
the big party the big hype you know like
we're gonna do it look at title even
with its recent success with some
exclusives I'm not bullish on that in
the long term I mean they you know they
had Madonna and hove and everybody's
there and like so I think way too many
people over promise and under deliver I
think way too many people try to sell on
the sizzle and not the steak and I would
say net net if we look at it Boober I
was there there's no there's no big
launch just worked right away I think if
we look at the top 150 apps you know
like know musically like what was the
launch for music like right like so I
would actually argue that most of the
apps that are successful didn't have
some big launch early momentum is good
but we've seen early momentum fade very
quickly I think your thesis or your
business has
matter I think at the end of the day
this is absolutely tortoise and hare and
I think the turtle wins every time and
so I think that uh well I think it has a
lot to do with ego and it feels really
good in that first year you're a founder
and you're cool and you're hot you might
be on the cover of a magazine and being
featured on TechCrunch but I I just
don't think it's how you start I think
it's how you finish and very honestly I
would tell you that most of my
confidence and most of this it thing
that you guys feel and most of this swag
or whatever the hell you want to call it
comes from me knowing what's gonna
happen when I'm 70 not what's happening
right now I feel like I'm gonna be
cemani and watch this moment one day and
I'm like man I was so young I had so
much in front I thought it was old at 40
but I was so young good show yes what
are you doing right now
I'm still in the show Tyler with a
rookie mistake I don't know how you and
AJ rolled but I'm still in show mode
here ty question of the day what's the
biggest mistake that you made recently
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
what's up guys hope you enjoyed the show
please do I get to link it up anywhere
is it like in here or is it down below
is it in print or is it in my video it's
here down to my left
like right here there's a button for
them to subscribe to my YouTube video
yeah it's a little buggy thing that's
right guys click this that's right use
that